let's be reasonable if a person insults
you then you have every right to fight
to the death in order to restore your
honor as you'll have noticed we don't
duel anymore but why not
when did Julian become illegal and why
did people want it to stop
now the height of dueling occurred
around the late 18th and early 19th
centuries but Jordan continued in some
countries into the 20th in Britain and
Russia formal codes of chivalry were
drawn up and sold alongside sets of
dueling pistols and as late as 1894 the
Russian Tsar Alexander the 3rd signed
off on legislation formalizing how
Russian officers were allowed to jewel
each other however you should know that
in wider Russian society the practice of
jailing was dying off and largely seen
as barbaric whereas in France Zhu Ling
was banned by louis xiv who saw them as
needless spilling of blood yet the last
jewel there took place in 1967 now for
the most part although there were
regional differences Jules worked like
this a person would say or do something
to insult another and the insulted party
would demand satisfaction satisfaction
being either an apology or a Jew now not
everyone could challenge everyone a
junior officer in the army couldn't
challenge general or a high-ranking
member of the nobility for example now
you didn't have to accept and put your
life on the line but it could lead to
you being called a coward and that
wouldn't do if you did accept then as
the one being challenged too often had
the right to choose the weapon used most
commonly swords or pistols for example
in Germany or Italy swords were commonly
used whereas in Britain the US and
Russia pistols were much more common and
of course more deadly anyway after
choosing your weapons you would meet at
a set time and date and there would be a
last chance to come to an agreement you
would bring your second with you that is
a close friend and representative to
hash things out with your opponent
second and if nothing could be agreed on
then it was fight time so why did Julian
fall out of favor well for a start the
fact that so many young officers were
killing each other meant that it was
affecting Britain and America's ability
to wage war George Washington for
example had issues with stopping
officers from killing each other during
the war for independence another reason
was that there were concerns especially
in the church that many people were
using Jews as a means to legally commit
suicide an accusation thrown at
Alexander Hamilton and a fear that was
especially prevalent in the United
States in Britain there was a great deal
of outrage in the 19th century as many
wealthy aristocrats were able to kill in
the duel and walk free the reasons why
journalists got off with literal
premeditated murder was because the
judges came from the upper classes and
were very sympathetic to the idea
of personal honor in the u.s. Jew lling
was banned fairly early on in many of
the northern states but these laws
weren't enforced when Aaron Burr killed
Hamilton he was charged with murder but
none of these stuck because I mean it
was a jewel between two upstanding
citizens and they both knew the risks
whilst in the northern states the Jew
was fairly rare as of the early 19th
century is staid popular in the south
particularly in South Carolina where new
drooling etiquettes were written in the
1830s and it was the Civil War that
finally killed Zhu Ling in America so
many people dying really took the shiner
for shooting your fellow Americans over
things like honor now Julian had always
been subject to some mockery but as of
the Victorian era people began to see it
as horrendously outdated as the
conditions of modern warfare became
widely known the notion of the
aristocracy somehow being able to
maintain their honor by shooting someone
in Wimbledon was seen as laughable and
in the end across Britain in America the
Jews slowly fell out of fashion
it wasn't legislated away as such with
though jeweling in the military died out
in Britain when widows pensions were
withheld from men killed in Jews instead
children saw a slow death as a pro
middle-class culture changed to a more
moderate means of settling scores
lawsuits I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching with the
special thanks to my patreon supporters
who you can see on screen here and with
an extra special thanks to James
Bissonnette David archaeologist
party-boy Co Danny Maloney Colin
Castleman Rob Waterhouse Aaron the white
Michael Reynolds H way in Emperor Chris
wicker Gustav Swann
Gareth Turner spinning three plates
David Silverman Winston Cawood Maggie
packs Kowski Christian check' Anthony
Beckett Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell and
Ike